bonjour à toutes et à tous désolé du
retard bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
vidéo dédiée à Deadpool 3 et du coup bah
le grand retour de Wolverine joué par
Hugh Jackman bon en vrai je suis désolé
pour mon retard mais si on relativise
c'est tôt voire même très tôt pour
parler de Deadpool 3 nous n'avons aucune
information pour le moment pas même un
synopsis nous savons juste surtout que
le film sort par en septembre 2024 donc
tout ça c'est loin très loin néanmoins
je pense que vous le savez je n'aime pas
trop faire des vidéos pour ne rien dire
donc s'il y a une vidéo sur Deadpool 3
et bien c'est quand même que j'ai pas
mal de choses à vous raconter il y a
moyen de déduire certaines choses bon
bien évidemment les fans les plus
aguerris de Marvel n'auront aucun mal à
trouver des réponses concernant
l'arrivée de Deadpool et de Wolverine
mais je me dis que c'est pertinent quand
même de faire une vidéo mais lente à la
fois théorie et explications pour que
tout le monde cerne très bien du sujet
comme je vous l'ai dit nous n'avons
aucune information sur le film à part sa
date de sortie et du coup bah le retour
de Wolverine donc tout ce que je vais
vous dire peut-être faux peut-être vrai
peu importe le but actuellement et
simplement de théoriser et d'expliquer
possiblement le film Deadpool 3 avec
pour simplement source la déduction donc
voilà est-ce que vous êtes prêts et bien
c'est parti on y va
tout d'abord il faut faire une grande
remise en contexte de la situation de
Deadpool et de ses films je sais que
beaucoup sont intrigués du retour de
Wolverine tout simplement à cause du
film Logan mais rassurez-vous tout est
explicable Deadpool fait partie de la
chronologie des films X-Men on ne va pas
trop s'étendre sur les explications de
cette chronologie de film car entre les
vieux les reboots les suites le voyage
dans le temps de days of future past cet
univers est très complexe à cerner il y
avait plusieurs visions et idées des
créateurs qui rentraient en
confrontation pour le développement des
X-Men et du coup la saga on a subi les
conséquences mais voilà ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que Deadpool fait partie
de cet univers donc les films X-Men
comme l'affrontement final apocalypse le
film Logan etc etc et du coup vu que
Deadpool 3 sera la première apparition
de Deadpool dans le MCU et qui étant
donné que c'est le troisième film du
personnage qui reste le même cela veut
donc dire que par le biais de Deadpool 3
l'univers des X-Men est désormais canon
omcu prenez l'exemple de Spider-Man Noé
room par le biais du multivers Toby
Maguire et Andrew Garfield sont apparus
dans l'univers du MCU et par conséquent
cela veut dire que leurs univers
respectifs font désormais partie de
l'histoire du MCU comme un univers
alternatif présent dans l'immensité du
multivers c'est exactement le même
procédé et c'est à ce moment que les
choses se compliquent car bien
évidemment nous savons qu'à terme
Deadpool va rester dans le MCU ce qui
veut dire que ce dernier va quitter
l'univers des X-Men pour atterrir et
continuer ses aventures dans celui du
MCU du coup comment expliquer tout ça de
manière cohérente et bien pour être tout
à fait honnête je pense qu'une grande
partie de la réponse se trouve dans le
concept de voyage dans le temps
rappelez-vous
poule c'est à dire nous troller avec le
voyage temporel mais vu que l'univers
X-Men va devenir canon omcu cela veut
donc dire que cet univers va se plier
aux règles des films du MCU par
conséquent les voyages temporels de
Deadpool auront des conséquences si l'on
suit la logique du MCU à portée
notamment par la série Loki Deadpool a
donc créé des Nexus c'est à dire des
branches alternatives ou un événement à
modifier le cours de l'Histoire et c'est
là où pour moi nous pouvons déduire
certaines choses
[Musique]
rappelez-vous de Spider-Man Noé room il
y a quelque chose que je n'ai pas arrêté
de vous rabâcher à l'époque c'est ce que
j'appelle en gros le phénomène de cahier
des charges en gros chaque héros chaque
personnage possède quelque chose qui lui
est propre ils ont tous leur histoire
ils ont tous leurs comics et s'ils
doivent être adaptés en film Marvel se
doit de respecter l'essence même des
personnages ainsi que leurs histoires
dans les comics et justement par rapport
à nose home Sony avait déjà adapté
énormément de thématiques fortes de
Spiderman énormément de vilains ou même
d'histoire propre à Peter Parker des
comics sauf un élément qui caractérise
plus que tout autre l'histoire de
Spiderman c'était le spider-verse le
fait que Peter prenne conscience qu'il
existe d'autres Peter Parker et qu'ils
se rencontrent est l'un des événements
les plus connus et apprécier des comics
donc il fallait que ce soit adapté en
film pour faire évoluer Spider-Man
est-ce que vous comprenez l'idée que
j'essaye de vous transmettre terminons
cet aparté en revenant à Deadpool ce que
je veux vous dire c'est que ce syndrome
de cahier des charges est adaptable à
chaque héros et à chaque personnage de
Marvel y compris des poules et pour moi
s'il y a bien un élément fort qui
caractérise complètement l'essence même
Deadpool et son histoire et qui en plus
colle parfaitement à la situation de
Deadpool 3 ce sont les variants du
personnage Deadpool possède un nombre
incalculable de versions de lui-même
dans les comics des versions qui sont
complètement loufoques comme des
versions qui sont tout à fait sérieuses
par exemple dans les comics il existe
une version Deadpool où il est fusionné
avec Venom une autre avec Galactus
carrément avec modoch ou même
complètement absurde une version
dinosaure bref les étoiles sont alignées
des poules voyage désormais dans le
temps avec la logique MCU il crée des
Nexus et donc des branches alternative
qui donc multiplie et donne naissance à
d'autres Deadpool et vu que c'est un
événement important des comics le fait
que Deadpool est de nombreux variants
qu'ils rencontrent voir qu'il affronte
et bien il y a moyen de mettre tout ça
en place et par la même occasion nous
amener pourquoi pas une version
maléfique de Deadpool comme il en existe
dans les comics et qui pourrait incarner
le rôle de vilain du film imaginez un
seul instant un combat opposant notre
Deadpool avec un autre Deadpool tout
aussi tropesque mais avec de mauvaises
intentions qui du coup aurait été créé
par notre Deadpool dû à ses voyages dans
le temps franchement je sais pas vous
mais moi c'est quelque chose qui me
donne envie en tout cas mais du coup que
vient faire Wolverine dans tout ça en
réalité on ne va pas se mentir la
présence de Wolverine dans le film et
purement fin de service à la base Ryan
Reynolds et Hugh Jackman sont de très
grands amis en plus il y a une scène
post-générique supprimée dans Dead 2 ou
des poules informe Wolverine que le jour
où ses aventures continuent et qu'il
aura besoin de lui il ira le chercher et
Wolverine devra accepter donc voilà en
revanche il est clair qu'il y a un désir
d'adapter l'histoire des comics tout
comme ils l'ont fait avec Deadpool 2
wide et Kable ont partagé d'innombrables
histoires et aventures dans les comics
il forme un sacré duo et c'est pareil
avec Wolverine les deux personnages
possèdent pas mal d'histoires dans les
comics et personnellement je trouve que
Deadpool brille beaucoup plus quand il a
un acolyte qui quant à lui et beaucoup
plus sérieux et du coup forcément bah
Wolverine va apparaître à cause d'un
voyage dans le temps c'est un procédé
qui permettra de laisser le film Logan
là où il est on ne touche à rien de ce
qui a été établi on crée simplement un
Nexus ou l'histoire de Wolverine va
changer comme il s'est passé avec Loki
dans endgame et du coup cela va donner
la possibilité de créer une nouvelle
histoire et du neuf pour Wolverine
sachant qu'en plus
on reprend X-Men Origins Wolverine nous
étions face à une version de Wade Wilson
transformée par Striker en arme 11 et
Wolverine va justement réussir à en
arriver à bout donc si l'on suit l'idée
de départ que je vous partage avec une
possible version maléfique de Deadpool
voilà où elle verrine est capable de
confronter des poules et dans arriver à
bout bref tout ça c'est bien sympa mais
cela ne répond pas à la question qui à
la base est comment Deadpool va changer
d'univers avec tout ce dont je viens de
vous parler je pense qu'une réponse vous
paraît peut-être évidente actuellement
c'est que le TVA intervienne à cause des
nombreux Nexus que Deadpool pour écrire
néanmoins je vous avoue que j'ai du mal
avec cette idée pourquoi cela et bien
tout simplement qu'avec les événements
de la série Loki le TVA a changé à tout
jamais avec la prise de conscience que
les employés étaient tous des variants
kidnappés Mobius et be fifting ont fait
le choix d'aband le flux temporel sacré
ce qui en soit veut dire les secours au
multivers de redevenir ce qu'il était
sachant qu'en plus celui qui demeure a
été tué et invariant de ce dernier
similaire à Kang et censé apparaître et
comme on nous l'attisait à la fin de
Loki il n'est pas prévu d'isoler à
nouveau le flux temporel sacré donc
voilà Deadpool et censé rester
tranquille en gros cependant une réponse
me paraît censée comme vous le savez
nous allons à terme nous diriger vers
Avengers Secret Wars et Secret Wars si
vous vous rappelez bien c'est
l'événement majeur qui traduit la guerre
multiverselle en gros le multivers se
contracte et en résulte énormément
d'incursion ou les univers vont rentrer
en collision ce qui va aboutir à la fin
du multivers et à la mort de la totalité
des univers que l'on connaît et c'est
pour moi bah la réponse la plus censée
pourquoi me direz-vous et bien déjà tout
simplement par rapport aux dates de
sortie et la cohérence que cela apporte
qui nous expliquait dans Docteur Strange
2 si Deadpool en vient à créer des Nexus
et par conséquent à donner naissance à
d'autres univers Deadpool sera à terme
dans des univers dont il n'est pas
présent à l'origine ceux qui pourraient
donner naissance à des incursions mais
bon tout ça c'est encore flou et peu
exploité dans le MCU les variants de
Docteur Strange ont causé des incursions
à cause des rêves passerelles si l'on
suit mot pour mot cette logique le Peter
Parker de Toby et Andrew aurait dû
causer des incursions pareil pour le
vautour avec Morbius etc etc donc je ne
suis pas sûr que cela soit la véritable
raison néanmoins n'oublions pas que
septembre 2024 c'est à la fois très loin
et à la fois très proche de la phase 6
ce qui veut dire que nous serons dans la
préparation et la mise en place
d'Avengers the Kang dynastie et Avengers
Secret Wars donc il se peut que des
poules ne causent pas véritablement
d'incursion mais plutôt pourquoi pas
qu'il en soit victime du possiblement au
complètement les sens même du personnage
de Ried Richards au vu de la sortie
proche de Deadpool 3 et le film Quatre
Fantastiques rides toujours sur ses
gardes par rapport aux menaces externes
à l'univers pourraient détecter la
présence de Deadpool due à l'arrivée
d'une incursion incursion qui je le
rappelle est la spécialité de
redrichards cela serait un bon moyen
d'introduire le personnage dans le MCU
et en plus de cela d'éduquer notre
riedry charts à ce phénomène pour qu'il
soit prêt pour Avengers Secret Wars
puissent actuellement seul Docteur
Strange est conscient de ce concept et
malheureusement il n'est actuellement
plus disponible
pour conclure il reste un point plus
profond que nous devons aborder si pour
moi c'est logique des pôles et Wolverine
apparaissent dans le MCU par le biais
d'une incursion et bien cela veut donc
dire que l'univers des films X-Men va
devoir rentrer en collision avec un
autre et sachant en plus que Deadpool
est censé rester dans l'univers du MCU
et bien cela soulève des points dont
l'importance n'est pas à négliger déjà
pourquoi Deadpool resterait-il dans le
MCU au lieu de rentrer chez lui le truc
c'est que nous pourrions nous dire qu'il
finirait piéger dans le MCU dans le sens
où après s'être perdu à cause de ses
voyages et pourquoi pas la possible
incursion il n'aurait plus accès au
gadget de Kable et n'aurait donc plus
moyen de se déplacer et voilà cependant
c'est quelque chose de plutôt illogique
car premièrement impossible que Deadpool
est envie de rester dans le MCU puisque
toute sa vie ses proches sa femme qu'il
a sauvé sont dans un autre en plus de
cela ride Richards a bien mis en garde
Docteur Strange sur le sujet qui a
forcément dû en parler avec Wong mais en
gros hors de question de garder la
présence d'un personnage provenant d'un
autre univers car il y a la peur d'un
déclenchement d'une incursion
americachevez n'ayant pas d'univers
propre vu qu'elle est un Nexus being bah
du coup elle par exemple elle peut
rester et justement tiens America Chavez
ayant le pouvoir de voyager à travers le
multivers elle pourrait tout simplement
partir avec des poules à la recherche de
son univers à lui pourtant tout ça c'est
bizarre et cela cache quelque chose
puisque Marvel ne souhaite pas reboot le
personnage de Deadpool ils veulent que
ce soit le même et qu'il continue ses
aventures dans le MCU contrairement il
semblerait au X-Men puisque déjà nous
serons face à un nouveau Wolverine et
que comme la démontré par exemple
shihulk il prévoit des choses pour
l'arrivée des X-Men et tout ça cela
reste secret contrairement à des poules
il ne nous disent pas qu'ils vont reboot
les x-m ou alors bien amener les anciens
nous n'avons aucune information bah
contrairement justement comme je disais
à Deadpool où les intentions sont très
claires donc est-ce que Deadpool 3
signifierait la mort de l'univers des
X-Men je me pose sincèrement la question
en fait si l'on suit les comics mais
également Doctor Strange 2 il n'existe
pas de véritables solutions pour stopper
une incursion actuellement la seule
issue possible c'est que lors d'une
incursion l'un des deux univers
détruisent celui d'en face donc on parle
bien de la mort d'un univers entier et
du coup cela permettrait la survie d'un
des deux univers élément qui pour moi
expliquerait pourquoi Deadpool resterait
dans le MCU car il n'aurait plus de
maison son univers serait éteint et pour
le développement de la saga Marvel
pourrait complètement couper les ponts
avec les films de la Fox leur permettant
de développer leur propre X-Men surtout
que si nous relativisons la stratégie de
Marvel concernant les mutants semble
plutôt explicite ils n'ont pas la
tension le groupe dxmen d'un coup ils
ont envie de tiser petit à petit les
mutants pour ensuite être libre de
développer l'intrigue qu'ils veulent ce
que je veux dire c'est que depuis
quelque temps Marvel nous indique
clairement l'arrivée petit à petit de
mutant dans le MCU Kamala Cannes alias
Miss Marvel a été annoncé comme mutante
Namor dans Black Panther est un mutant
Wanda du coup l'est aussi à forte chance
même si ils n'ont jamais développé la
question et du coup bah petit à petit de
fil en aiguille il nous ramène les
mutants il nous refont le coup avec
Wolverine et Deadpool ils amènent deux
Nouveaux Mutants qu'on va additionner au
précédent etc etc est-ce que vous
comprenez l'idée mais voilà dans tous
les cas il existe plusieurs questions
profondes concernant l'arrivée de
Deadpool dans le MCU bon bien évidemment
nous n'avons pas d'informations mais je
pense que Marvel studio souhaite
conserver le même Deadpool car il serait
le vestige de la saga des films X-Men et
de leur univers comme un héritage en
quelque sorte surtout que un reboot en
URL le développement du personnage de
Wade comme je vous disais l'essence même
de Deadpool c'est qu'ils prennent
conscience des autres versions de
lui-même et qu'il les rencontre voire
les confrontes Deadpool un grand rôle à
jouer dans la saga du multiversse et
redévelopper un nouveau Deadpool et lui
créer une nouvelle histoire c'est perdre
tout ça contrairement aux autres X-Men
qu'ils pourront re-développer et puis de
toute façon il est clair et même sûr à
1000% que nous aurons des héros des
X-Men à l'issue de Secret Wars puisque
n'ayant plus d'univers beaucoup de
personnages devront cohabiter dans ce
restant mais voilà nous aurons
l'occasion de reparler du phénomène des
X-Men dans le MCU à l'avenir
et je pense que nous allons nous arrêter
là pour être tout à fait honnête j'étais
prêt à encore vous écrire plusieurs
pages de contenu que ce soit sur les
X-Men les Quatre Fantastiques les
incursions etc tout simplement parce
qu'il y a plein de choses à dire mais
bon je pense que nous allons commencer
la petite à petit à nous écarter du
sujet donc voilà tout ça ce sera pour
une prochaine fois il y a plein de
choses à dire j'espère en tout cas vous
avoir éclairé concernant Deadpool 3
comme je vous ai dit c'est très tôt pour
en parler on a aucune information
seulement la date de sortie et le retour
de Wolverine mais voilà je vous ai
partagé ma vision propre à moi donc vous
en faites ce que vous voulez tout
peut-être faut tout peut-être vrai j'ai
essayé simplement de me baser sur la
déduction et les règles du Marvel
cinématique Universe si ma vidéo vous a
plu n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit
pouce bleu qui soutient énormément mon
travail je suis toujours là pour essayer
de vous accompagner d'expliquer Marvel
le plus possible n'hésitez pas également
à partager vos idées vos avis en
commentaire je les lis toujours et bien
évidemment n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
on approche à très très grand pas des
cent mille abonnés donc voilà un très
grand merci à tous let's go sur ce les
amis c'était argorock que le Lionel
heart soit avec vous allez ciao tout le
monde
[Musique]